the stars of the Met Gala who are
dealing with their Met Gala hangover
nischelle Turner joining us from New
York she looks good though folks on I
letting up though on Kim K I know it
slipped out one time one time just roll
on because people are not give it a
letting up on Kim Kardashian her waist
snatching look well it's freaking a lot
of people out but Kim you know was
standing by her style and now we know
exactly how she pulled it off
okay so Anna if I don't sit down for
dinner now you know why I'll be walking
around mingling talking but I can only
like half sick Kim's organs squishing
corset was made to give her an 18 inch
waist and as the glam team laced her in
Kim basically said make it smaller
it's made out of silicone so second out
latex Oh
Vogue's covergirl had to stand up in a
van on the way to the met and had a
tough time walking and couldn't use the
restroom for four hours just wish me
luck just wish me luck as for how Kim
pulled off that cinched in look for the
after-party that bloom ooh glare dress
had a sheer panel with a belly button
painted in so she could still wear that
corset underneath
JLo was also waist obsessed as she got
ready for the met giving her team
instructions to make her look smaller
Vogue also took us inside the dressing
room with cardi B how'd cardi pull off
these flat abs under her dress cardi
finally confessed she had lipo oh love
that honesty
remember when she told Edie this I just
got my boobs redone but this is a hassle
yeah and feeling good yes my daughter
yeah
[Music]